[Music]
you built a thing called wordplay is it
wordplay.com it's wordplay.com right
by the way you buy domain name so you
bought the hustle.com for us you bought
me
copythat.com thank you for that um i
forgot to say thank you in person but uh
uh so you buy like a lot of amazing
domains but you have wordplay.com and
did you tweet that it was getting seven
million users a week or three what was
the number what so the
i just went and checked the numbers okay
so just to kind of
place the timeline in frame so november
and december of last year 2021 is when
wordle took off in january is when it
really kind of hit it's i think close to
its peak um and that's roughly when the
new york times acquired wordle
and
a couple things kind of i mean it was
fine i think it was um a great outcome
for josh wordle but there were things
that were kind of bothering me that were
limitations in the game and i was an
avid player of the game um and now it's
like okay well the new york times has
bought it there is no way anything's
going to happen for like years if ever
so that was kind of thing number one
thing number two like it was uh it had
been a while since i had launched like
some simple free thing publicly uh
hadn't gone through the process and
there were other things i wanted to
learn it's like oh i want to learn more
about versailles and xjs and typescript
and things like that so it's like okay
well this is a
excuse and then that intersected with
the third thing which was like the
dominant variable in the equation is my
son was taking a python programming
class he's 11 right he's going through
this process
and for him um
it's still very abstract he's learning
programs he enjoys everything involving
technology and screens but it was
abstract so on a saturday night i said
okay well
let me build something python happens to
be my language um
build something so he can see because he
plays world he knows the game um and so
i started on saturday night with a
deadline for sunday that i'm going to
launch something with him tomorrow we're
going to have google analytics on it so
we're going to launch it i'm going to
launch it by tweeting it and so he knows
what social media is right he's um you
know so i'm like oh we've got this thing
that didn't exist yesterday
i wrote the code over the course of last
night in python the language that you're
learning and we're going to launch it
and now you can see users coming in
right you can see and so now what i want
him to have in his head is that when he
has through the course of his life as he
encounters problems that are solvable
with software which is a lot
like it's actually tactile for him it's
like oh i don't know i don't have the
skills right now to do what you know dad
just did but i know it's possible i know
it's possible because he did it in the
span of 24 hours right so if i want to
go off and build a video game i want to
go off and build some tool for my school
i want to build some social network for
my whatever it is
it feels like now it's it's more
approachable for him he's got years to
go before he'll get to that level but um
anyway so those three things sort of
came together and so we launched it
on that sunday this is i think in
february or so give or take
um and since then it's had like 45
million games have been played uh nine
and a half million people have come
through it
um
any given moment in time right now for a
look at the google analytics should be
two three thousand people playing like
right now um
which
how did it get so much traffic where did
the traffic come from well it helps that
i have a social media following right
i've got a million followers on linkedin
i've got 300 000 on twitter so there's
that
uh there are some things
that that's that's a lot but
that's not i wouldn't have thought that
yeah yeah it's not enough for that is it
how many users you think got from that
um
in the early days was it big was it big
right off the bat like the first week
was it big i know the first day probably
a bunch of people checked it out but
like i'm sure you posted it and that was
the big surge so what was like the first
week roughly do you remember the first
week was probably maybe 50 to 100 000 so
it was it wasn't a lot but it was
something uh but then once you kind of
get into it this is the
you know kind of power of iteration is
that oh well one of the things that i
found missing in the original wordle was
that it was a single player game like
you played and you played once a day and
that was it uh so two big changes that
we made in wordplay one was it was
unlimited play you didn't you didn't
have to play just once a day and two
it it allowed you to challenge your
friends so you could say oh i just
played this word i solved it in four
turns here's my score and send literally
a simple link to anyone or a group on
and this happens
tens of thousands of times right like
someone will take a link that they just
play they're really proud of their score
and then their family they can post it
through whatsapp group they can post it
their you know wherever they want and
say i invite you to like beat my score
kind of thing um
and so that's the viral element and so
then as more people play you can track
that as you might as a google analytics
event and say how many people how many
times are people clicking that share
button and issuing challenges to other
people and so that
once you can kind of get into something
where there's a compounding effect on
the user base so as a user base grows um
and so now the thing i'm fighting though
right is that so that's happening that's
going well but then the interest in
wordle uh in related games is waiting
because everything has its kind of peak
in its uh and its ebb um
and so but
it's been an interesting exercise so on
the kind of learning path one of the
things i hadn't done in a while is like
okay well what's traffic actually worth
let's say i had to make a living on this
thing or make the company quote-unquote
or project profitable so i put google
adsense on it which is the easiest thing
to do
and discovered that
like
if i weren't bothered by the fact that
there would be two ads on the main game
board page if i were solving for
monetization it was like ninety thousand
dollars a month
uh in google analytics oh
traffic yeah wow i thought you were
gonna say way less
yeah i thought he's gonna say like five
grand a month but 90 grand a month and
you're you only have your only costs are
hosting right
yeah and and my time
right and
first of all sean go to wordplay.com and
then go to like the about page his about
page is incredibly well written it's
wonderful copywriting it's wonderful
uh you've got a wonderful voice it says
uh i'll just read the first sentence but
it says why would you do this
or the better yet why would i do this
that's a really good question
my wife asked me the same question and
then you like go on to explain why it
just you you're you're quite a good
writer for also being like this amazing
engineer typically those
power writing course that sean put on
you know that right let's like i'm not
right
around here with my alumni
[Laughter]
i like to say i taught darmesh
everything he knows even before he met
me i somehow caught him all that good
stuff before he built hubspot
what uh what do you so this is making 90
grand a month maybe or about what do you
is it it could it's not right there's no
advertising i turn the ads off because
that's a point and people are asking me
is like darmash why do you have ads on
this thing and like
to learn like it's like i've learned
what i needed to learn so i can
was was tweeting and linkedin posting
this on linkedin the only way you got
users what do you think this could sell
for right now and is the is this the
biggest side project you've ever created
our buddy tried to buy it silly tried to
buy it off you
did he really he
he tweeted out he's like i'd like to buy
this off you i've you know i've built
mobile games before you know he was like
semi serious at least i don't know i
don't know if you talk to him or not but
i did not
what do you think you could say what do
you think like if you cared what do you
think you could sell it for
two or three million dollars maybe right
now that um let's say the ad revenue
would go down to like 50 000 or
something like that because i haven't
turned google adsense in a while that's
600 000 a year
apply a 5x multiple um
so somewhere between two and 10 million
dollars would be my guess if i like if
that's what we're solving for so
and um is this the was was posting it on
linkedin and twitter the only way that
you got users or did you do some other
weird hacks i had my blog uh had my it's
like i'm a big believer in like you know
what folks call like the flywheel
there's all these little things that are
attached to the flywheel right it's like
oh well linkedin helps a little bit puts
a little energy twitter does a little
bit and i have my blog and the email
goes out and there's like things that i
sort of do
um
yeah so it it helps but it's like the
hardest part is that cold start problems
like how do you get your first hundred
thousand people a hundred to a thousand
people um and then it's a matter of like
tracking the retention rate on those
users they come back the other thing
that's been interesting about wordplay
as far as the lesson learned um is that
you know when it started the average
time a user spent according to google
was roughly four minutes um on the game
okay um in the early weeks and now that
number is at 14 minutes is the average
time a user spends um you know across
however many a thousand users come in a
given day so right what uh and is this
the biggest side project you've ever
created
uh depends on how you measure it um so
technically no not in terms of just like
raw traffic um i've built graders and
things like that before that uh have
done better but
what have you built that what side
project have you built outside of
hubspot that gets more traffic than
two or three people really did side
projects this was my first one um that
was like clearly because it was a game
had it been anything other than a game i
would have rationalized some way to
bring it into the spot umbrella because
i like to have like all my eggs in that
basket uh but just given the
circumstances here didn't really make
sense um and even now like i'm thinking
about uh doing a uh kind of a marketing
and sales related
edition of wordplay right it's like oh
the entire list of words or uh do it
based on martech companies like okay do
you know the the players in the space
kind of thing and then you can get
sponsorships or whatever anyway but um
yeah website greater was the
this kind of a project where it was like
a free i'm i really like low friction
things that people can come to the
website and this is why my son and i
were chatting yesterday is where i'm
looking at flutter this new development
environment and language um well darts
the language but flutter is the
uh the app framework for building mobile
apps across ios and android and things
like it's the what the cool new kids are
learning
and he's like no why would i ever want
to build a mobile app that's like
something people have to download i have
to get approval from you know apple to
kind of post my like i i want to like
just do it like immediately he's got uh
and he's right it's like okay anyway so
that's the word play story it's been
it's been a lot of fun i've um
it's hard to know with these things like
like where the road leads like wordplay
itself may or may not kind of connect
back to other things whatever but the
things i've learned through it
i think will it's like okay well here's
what it takes to build this kind of
thing it's like okay well then i'm using
it to
play around with community it's like
okay can i take the word play user base
what are things they care about and
build a community around wordplay using
all the existing kind of community
platforms um and and see if that's a
thing right it's like okay if you could
aggregate people with like interests um
that in itself has value and i wanted to
send you something that kind of self
runs but we'll see
[Music]